bob i i really i said it in the intro  you really have accomplished so much in  your career you've done it all you've  met  everybody and it occurred to me  there's so many people that are the  subject of a biopic these days  i think i mean given your incredible  career  you would be a great subject for a  biopic have you thought about who might  play you  uh i think the rock  wait dwayne the rock johnson yeah i get  mistaken for him a lot  hey dwayne and i said no way i'm not  duane  but there should there should be quite a  fight over it  yeah i um well i i i'm sure the rock is  you know very anxious to play that part  he could recreate your  he could recreate your football career  your early football career very good  that's right that's right him running  and shouting i don't have it would be a  lot of fun to see  i i brad pitt is supposed to be very  interested yeah yeah  you